hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in lecture 31 the dissection of the
psychical personality sigmund freud
sets out three important
agencies within the human personality
the super
ego the id and then the ego trapped
between them
in many respects and the ego is what is
it carrying out the
psychoanalysis and indeed scrutinizing
itself but also these these
other we want to call them faculties we
can all the freud
cautions against turning them into
things in that way and when we're
looking at the relations
between these this is really an
exemplary
essay in part because it shows us that
the relations
are not that simple there's several
different
ways we can look at them
and and one that you might want to think
about right off the bat
is this diagram that freud
actually provides where he says i would
like to portray the structural relations
of the mental personality
in this unassuming sketch which i
present you
with and we're gonna come back to that
you know
spatial representation in just a moment
but i think one that's you know more
helpful to begin with is
thinking about the genesis the
development
of these different agencies and the way
that that freud portrays
it within this is very clear is at first
we have the id
right and then the between the id
and the external world which the id is
really not equipped
to engage with on its own as a matter of
fact
the id by itself following the pleasure
principle would just get itself killed
in the external world there develops out
of the
id the ego and the ego
is quite different than the id in many
important respects in ways that we we've
discussed
elsewhere so the ego has this
important mediating function it derives
its energy from the id
it perceives and engages with the
external world
through the ego we have the introduction
of the
reality principle not just the pleasure
principle
and we've got this continual process we
could say
of adjustment a dialectic between all
three of these id
ego and external world and then
we have the the agency that freud began
this lecture with talking about the
super ego he tells us that the
super ego is in in many respects coming
later on and we see that it arises out
of the parental
function right so he says
in the case of what is phylogenetically
the last and most delicate of these
divisions
the differentiation between the ego and
the
super ego this is this is quite
important
right so we've got now these these three
things and the ego is essentially
the juncture between all three of these
and as we've seen
in other paragraphs freud talks about
the ego as having these three tyrannical
masters
we're not going to worry so much about
that at this point
now there is a earlier section where he
tells us after explaining what the
different meanings of
unconscious are and that one of them we
can call the pre-conscious and now we
have these three things the
conscious the pre-conscious and the
unconscious
he tells us that we don't want to
identify
ego id superego in whatever combination
with these three that would be a big
mistake
on our part he says i suspect you feel
dissatisfied because the three qualities
of the characteristic of consciousness
and the three provinces of the mental
apparatus
do not fall together into three piece
peaceable couples
you may regard this as in some sense
obscuring
our our you know obscuring our findings
right
and you know this is actually a very
good point to dwell on a little bit of a
digression
there's a tendency to want to
oversimplify when it comes to
engaging in anything that's trying to
understand you know human nature
and the faculties capacities agencies
whatever you want to call them
within us there's a tendency for example
to see
three things ego superego and id and say
aha that looks like the platonic
tripartite division of the soul
those are mistakes you don't want to
make easy identifications
because that although it may feel
satisfying
actually obscures what is supposed to be
having some clarity brought to it
so we don't want to try to produce a
fake identity
and here freud has a really cool analogy
that is worth dwelling on he says
i'm imagining a country with a landscape
of varying configuration we've got hill
country
planes and chains of lakes so it sounds
like a nice place to be in doesn't it
and then he says there's a mixed
population it's inhabited by germans
magors hungarians and slovaks
and these people carry on different
activities so so far so good
now we can make generalizations like we
can say well the germans tend to live
up in the hills and there they engage in
cattle breeding that's their main
activity
up there and the magors live in the
plains and there they grow cereals what
we call grains right
and produce wine and then the slovox
live within this chain of lakes
and as such they do a lot of fishing and
they also
take reeds and plate them into baskets
and now we've got something like a
you know fairly primitive economy going
on there presumably
the germans are also you know tanning
leather and stuff like that and
everybody's getting what they need
but everybody's got their nice place
right just
just germans in the hills just uh
slovaks in the lakes
and freud says is it ever really like
that
no of course not he says
things might be partitioned in a way
that there's you know
tendencies uh if the partitioning could
be neat and clear-cut like this a
woodrow wilson would be delighted by it
what's he talking about there woodrow
wilson was
part of the division of the
austro-hungarian empire
woodrow wilson was an american president
right and after world war one the allies
divided up all these
places that had previously been parts of
larger empires
into their own ethnic new nations
right and some of the boundaries were
rather
arbitrary but the idea was you know
hungarians should live in hungary and
romanians should live in romania
and you know so on and so forth so he
says
um the probability is you will find less
orderliness and more
mixing if you travel through the region
germans magos slovaks live
interspersed all over it in the hill
country there is
agricultural land as well cattle are
bred in the plains too
a few things are naturally as you
expected fish cannot be caught in the
mountains
wine does not grow in the water but in
the
for the most part there's going to be a
lot more diffusion inter penetration
going on
and freud is saying that to suggest to
us that
although we can draw kind of a map
of the territory of the psyche there's a
lot of bleeding
over into each other of these
different parts and so when he produces
this
iconic representation for us
we have to be kind of careful with it
and he he cautions
us uh he says as you see here the super
ego
merges into the id indeed as heir to the
oedipus complex that has intimate
relations with the id
it is more remote than the ego from the
perceptual system
the id has intercourse with the external
world only through the ego
at least according to this diagram that
is
very important and and freud follows
this up by saying
it is certainly hard to say today how
far the drawing
is correct in one respect it is
undoubtedly not
the space occupied by the unconscious id
ought to have been
incomparably greater than that of the
ego or the pre-conscious i
ask you to correct it in your thoughts
so this is not supposed to be
taken as like the final word uh the
map that is you know everything must
conform to
instead it's it's suggestive and he goes
on
to tell us that we got to be really
careful
about pictorial representations
he says in thinking of this division of
the personality into an ego
a super ego and an id you will not have
pictured sharp frontiers
like the artificial ones drawn in
political geography
once again a reference to you know
splitting ethnic
regions apart from each other he says we
cannot do justice to the characteristics
of the mind by linear outlines like
those in a drawing
or in primitive painting but rather by
areas of color
melting into one another as they are
presented by
modern artists so
melting into each other these agencies
ego superego id
are not like hard blocks that
you know are set down next to each other
rather they
interpenetrate each other they're names
for ways in which
things are happening within the psyche
that have
some you know lasting you could say
determination but in which there's a lot
of complex
interconnections things can be passed
off between them there are no actual
sharp boundaries instead what we have
are dynamic
systems that as freud tells us are
subject to change
and also subject to we might say
not just change through you know regular
processes of say maturation or family
dynamics
but interventions on our own part
which might produce different effects
and so he tells us
that you know some of this may result
from psychical illness
but certain mystical practices may
succeed in upsetting
the normal relations between the
different regions of the mind
so that for instance perception may be
able to grasp happenings in the depths
of the ego
and the id which were otherwise
inaccessible to it
he he says this is probably not going to
lead us to ultimate truths or salvation
as mystics often want to say
but those things could be quite useful
and we might have all sorts of other
techniques that give us more
insight into what's going on and as
that happens we are modifying the
the person in doing so right
and so this is also leading us to the
the culmination of this uh lecture where
he says where it was their ego shall be
it is a work of culture culture meaning
education
or development building where
we deliberately engage in although we
don't fully understand what we're doing
some modification of the psyche
in the process so these these areas
within ourselves not exactly the same as
geographic
topographical areas they they do have
important relations to each other
they're interconnected
they can't be you know say you can't cut
out the super
ego or cut out the id or remove the ego
as if you were going to carry out
a dissection perhaps freud's term here
is a little bit misleading
but this offers us at least a picture of
how these different parts of ourselves
are in fact interrelated according to
freud's
theory
you